thorough process has culminated in the
most serious sentence possible
aggravated life imprisonment on a person who
until a few years ago was a
practically unknown philanthropist to suffer a
public trial, a process that has also
dragged seven other
equally innocent citizens into the same wave of
blind revenge when  a
political system when an entire political system
culminates in a single person at a
vertex without checks and balances in the
end everything can be reduced to prejudices
or personal hobbies but that contaminates the
entire state and its international image it
is the current government of
turkey that has
deliberately decided to blow up
any prospect of resuming the
accession process not this parliament
not the commission not the council not the
member states the current
turkish government has closed that door for itself a
door that cannot be opened with this
turkey there are many aspects of the
relationship  those that we can continue
working with turkey but not from  and
then in the accession process and what
is worth us is to take advantage of the role of
mediation in the war as an alibi
to accelerate the domestic authoritarian process
not at least waiting for the
silence of this parliament and I hope that
neither the silence of the commission or the
council free the cabal and reverse the
current destructive trend of a not
so distant nascent democracy in
turkey thank you very much